Merciless but righteous,
I used that force to tap into the deeper
part of myself.
People will think I liked the coal too
much.
I don't like it.
I like a Walmart place.
I like palm trees.
I respect the cold very much.
It's my teacher
liberation war between heaven and earth.
But I couldn't find it.
And uh,
after years I found myself in the park
in Sunday morning,
everybody's sleeping and I was pondering
once again,
like always pause.
It doesn't stop,
you know,
the brain does the brain.
That brain doesn't stop if you really
search for something and yeah,
I've been founded.
Your brain just keeps on you,
your,
your into your mind.
So this Sunday morning I was walking
through the park and I just felt this
attraction to this thin layer of ice on
the water.
The idea came up.
I go into that world.
I am dressed myself.
When they intimidated water,
I played a little bit with the.
I didn't feel the cold whatsoever.
I found power,
power into power silenced and I came
back avalene game and it's so true.
A moment I began to become aware.
I was reading more,
deeper,
deeper and deeper breathing brought
about in Oksana,
Jason in my buddy tingling sensation.
I felt this is it.
I fall short.
We tap into the deepest part of our
brain which is pure feeling and it's
great and it hasn't got anything to do
with
after 30 years of mockery,
which I endured.
It's belief and now it's in the American
university books.
It's all their endocrine systems,
immune systems,
the chapter,
the iceman.
Nobody could say,
what you do is craziness.
What what?
What is life about?
What is the real sense of.
You cannot find it in their booth.
You gotta open up
the game to read,
to be conscious of what you have.